what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
members of the Rob core it's been a
little while since we covered any of
injustice two but that's largely because
of the fact that I've been going on all
kinds of trips recently and so I've just
been using stockpiled videos and haven't
really had a chance to make new ones so
we're making injustice to you again for
those of you guys who are new injustice
to basically picks up with what was
going on between the events of injustice
one and the injustice to games so the
comic is basically filling in the gaps
between those two things now of course
what injustice to really focus on
heavily in the beginning was the
aftermath of the fall of Superman's
regime in the sense that injustice one
basically focused on Superman rise into
power consolidating that power creating
basically this worldwide dictatorship
and really kind of creating a utopia
where people didn't war except for you
know Batman's whole you know insurgency
but the idea was that in the aftermath
of Superman's defeat the question people
had is what comes next well what this
initially began to do was focus on Ra's
al Ghul and the introduction of a new
Batman now this new Batman was basically
an ally of Ra's al Ghul we didn't really
know who he was all fingers point to the
idea that it's Jason Todd Red Hood just
a different iteration of his character
but we don't know for certain what is
kind of left to assume that that's the
case now the other half of this is that
Ra's al Ghul in this story is actually
returning to his classic roots and what
I mean by that is historically speaking
in DC Comics Ra's al Ghul in terms of
the most recent iterations and how
people view him is just a guy who
usually gets into fights with like
Batman or the Justice League or
something like that
but on the whole Ra's al Ghul is an
environmentalist all the actions that he
engages in are committed to the ideology
of purging humanity from the face of the
planet it's usually superheroes who get
in his way and so like they're the first
step to eliminating Humanity in its
entirety but that's always the goal is
to get rid of humanity and to allow
nature to flourish to its full potential
to restore things back to how he
perceives it as the way it's supposed to
be now a few things have happened in the
story so far there has been the return
of Supergirl but for what we're covering
here she's really not a part of this
story she's really kind of a non-starter
what this story really begins to focus
on is the aftermath of the death of Ted
Kord now Ted Kord was the second
iteration of Blue Beetle I believe and
really the most popular among fans but
the idea here is that with the death of
Ted Kord this was an attempt by Ra's al
Ghul
take out these titans of industry
basically individuals who in some former
fashion had contributed to what he
believed to be the wholesale slaughter
of the environment now of course this
also resulted in Jaime Reyes taking up
the mantle now this is kind of a flip on
the circumstances in the sense that
things are a little bit different here
with this fuel and everything that's
going on Jaime Reyes initially
approaches Bruce Wayne and simply says I
want to help you take down these guys
who are responsible for the death of Ted
Kord but this is totally different from
what we saw in the main DC line of
comics that when Infinite Crisis took
place Jaime Reyes was just this guy who
was imbued with the power of the Blue
Beetle and that was it there was really
no muss no fuss he kind of had to learn
how to become Blue Beetle on his own
absent training from Ted Kord in this
instance in injustice to he's trained by
Ted Kord to become the next Blue Beetle
so it's basically a passing of the
mantle that's how these two things
differ but the reason why this works is
because now this gives Jaime Reyes
motivation to see the defeat for the the
people who killed Ted quartz so again it
all flows together pretty well but it
still builds on what's already been
established in terms of the DC Universe
now the other half of this is that this
focus is largely on Black Canary and
Green Arrow and that's really where we
switch over to their two characters but
what I want to do for a second is I want
to sidetrack with a guy named Ted grant
now this is really the the wedding of
Black Canary and and Green Arrow really
the two of them is kind of coming
together remember Black Canary was
believed to have been dead but she was
basically rescued by dr. fate sort of
this guy who was the predecessor for
Marvel's Doctor Strange and so the idea
was that with dr. fate he had
effectively grabbed Black Canary
essentially healed her injuries and then
took her to an alternate universe where
Green Arrow had survived but had lost
his wife and so because of that in
injustice to both that alternate reality
Green Arrow and the injustice to Black
Canary were brought to the injustice to
universe along with her son Connor Hawke
and they've just kind of been here ever
since fighting alongside Batman but with
Ted grant he's a guy named Wildcat and I
do not know a whole lot about his
character honestly he's one of those
guys that always flew under my radar and
I think he's one of the guys that flew
under a lot of people's radars but when
it comes to Ted grant he's basically
this guy that has nine lives
quote-unquote now there is this idea
that he can only ever really die if he's
killed like nine times in the same cycle
but I don't know what that means the
whole idea of him having
lives is just sort of an in comic
explanation for the idea the Ted grants
basically immortal he can die and come
back almost any number of times but
again he also has history with Black
Canary just because of the fact that I
believed they both originated from
earth-2 in the main DC Comics but at the
very least the idea is that he's really
been you know kind of a mentor for her
in a lot of different ways so this leads
directly into one of the biggest reveals
of this story which is Damian Wayne
taking the corpse of Alfred with the
intention of resurrecting him now again
because of the fact that Bruce Wayne
always keeps these sort of alarms for
the various graves that exist for his
parents as well as Alfred as soon as
that grave is disturbed he bolts out of
that wedding like a bat out of hell and
immediately gets over to Wayne Manor
only to find out that Damian Wayne the
daughter of the bat and of course this
presumably Jason Todd Batman have the
corpse of Alfred and so this is
essentially going on as a distraction of
sorts because while that's taking place
the Suicide Squad is launching an attack
on the wedding of Green Arrow and black
Canary's so at this point the story
begins to sort of shift its focus and
emphasize primarily the events of Batman
and the possibility that Alfred could
really be resurrected and that's really
what it is it's really this idea that
Alfred will come back and that was one
of the most anticipated things just
because of the fact that Alfred was so
instrumental to the raising of Bruce
Wayne then in a lot of ways people
wanted to see him return in some form or
fashion even if it was just like a
hologram or something along those lines
Alfred's like the one guy you don't
touch the one guy you don't kill but the
other half of this is insurance for Ra's
al Ghul to simply say alright guys we
are going to destroy all of humanity
that's immediately gonna bring Batman
and his forces crashing down on him and
so in order to keep Batman at bay the
idea was to have some sort of insurance
policy and so this leads into Ra's al
Ghul kidnapping those kids and then
bringing them to his facility now again
this really brings into question the
trust of Batman and that's a non running
theme when it comes to his character
when it comes to Bruce Wayne it's always
the idea that you don't know if he can
ever really be trusted or not of course
this leads to Ra's al Ghul broadcasting
directly to Batman saying we have the
children of Jefferson Pierce we have the
children of Black Canary and Green Arrow
if you show up here we will kill them
this is really the ruthless nature of
Ra's al Ghul
we'll do whatever it takes in order to
achieve his goal he's woefully
disconnected from humanity with regards
to the value of the sanctity of life and
so because of this the revelation is
brought to Bruce Wayne that Ra's al Ghul
and company are in possession of Alfred
Pennyworth now the idea is that this is
going to be them basically saying hey
look if you come here not only what we
kill the kids will kill Alfred the issue
here is that Ra's al Ghul is hitching
his horse to the wrong carriage because
he believes that Batman will stay at bay
he believes that Batman will say okay
fine I will sacrifice the world to make
sure Alfred Pennyworth lives but Batman
wants to have his cake and eat it too
it's always been that way with his
character he wants to have it all and so
because of that Ra's al Ghul does not
understand Batman is going to come for
Alfred and the reason for this is
because of the fact that remember Batman
put a tracking device inside connor
hawke now this is when we started to get
into the whole whole idea of questioning
whether or not Batman can be trusted
because he did not tell Green Arrow
about this he did not tell Black Canary
about this and that's the way Batman
operates for the most part he plays it
close to the vest
Batman despite fighting alongside the
regime doesn't trust any of them and
that's why it's so big is because now
they realized that he sees them as
assets as a means to an end as opposed
to friends and legitimate allies but for
Batman you know you might as well yell
at him about this as you would yell at a
dog for barking at another dog it's just
in his nature it's what he does is how
he functions shrouded in secrecy playing
things close to the vest it's the nature
of his character and so because of this
what it ends up breaking down to is the
idea that their fight gets postponed for
a moment and what they come to the
realization of is if they are going to
infiltrate the fortress of Ra's al Ghul
then what they need is someone who can
never be seen what they need is someone
who can blend in to any situation
anywhere the person they need is Plastic
Man Plastic Man is one of the most
powerful beings in the entirety of the
DC Universe Plastic Man could take out
Superman just by virtue of filling as
long as with his win himself because
we're Plastic Man is malleable so we
could just jump into the body of
Superman and then just fill his lungs
with himself or a precious body or any
number of things Plastic Man is highly
durable and almost completely
indestructible the only way to take him
out is to basically freeze him and then
shatter him aside from that he can
increase his physical strength he can
increase his mask
can shrink down to any size he can
shape-shift into anything that's exactly
what it is he is so dangerous but we're
you also have O'Brien Plastic Man
you have his son Luke McDonough Plastic
Man and so you basically have to running
around now notice this it's kind of a
funny situation because when Batman goes
to see him he basically starts figuring
out every single form that Luke mcdonnen
is taking but the reason for this is
because of the fact that Luke's never
fought alongside Batman or at least
never in any real capacity O'Brien has
fought alongside Batman on a myriad of
occasions and so in this whole instance
when Batman is basically talking to Luke
and saying I need to get ahold of your
father we end up finding out his dad's
been there the entire time
in the form of Luke's wristwatch so
that's why this is so cool that's why
these characters are so dangerous is
because if you don't know how to deal
with them effectively they will kill you
now force this leads into you of course
the return of Jaime Reyes Jaime Reyes
basically wanted to find alongside
Batman in their efforts to basically
take out Rozelle rule again it's very
much just a vendetta situation here but
what this does is this brings in the
capabilities of Plastic Man both
offensively and defensively and so
because of this we're Plastic Man and
company were able to get Batgirl down to
the surface and that's really about it
at that point it turns with a question
of how do they infiltrate now of course
with batgirls knowledge of technology
different things like that it's taking
out the security systems taking out the
comm systems but the cool thing about
this is that at this point we switch
over to a conversation between Animal
Man and Damian Wayne and this is when
Tom Taylor brings into the equation the
question is Ra's al Ghul really wrong
for wanting to eliminate humanity and
the reason for this is because Ra's al
Ghul has set up this massive compound
for basically species that are on the
brink of extinction species that have
basically been hunted to extinction by
humanity because species don't normally
go arbitrarily extinct either they
totally exhaust their food supply as the
case was with a Megalodon shark they're
wiped out by some natural event like the
dinosaurs or people eliminate them and
so in this instance with Animal Man
being a guy that can basically tap into
the abilities of animals communicate
with animals different things like that
he tells the story about a rhino that
was basically the last of its kind and
it had his horns taken by poachers now
of course in response to this animal man
tracked the poachers down and killed him
but it raises some really interesting
questions is the world better off
without humanity
the beauty of this whole thing is that
people can also fix themselves they can
also make a better world and that's what
Ra's al Ghul does in grasp in his mind
he's looking for the quick and easy path
to a better world as opposed to the time
it takes to create a better world but
he's also looking at the idea that maybe
there is no better world at the end of
the horizon maybe there is no pot of
gold at the end of that rainbow that's
why it brings all these philosophical
arguments into the equation on whether
or not what Ra's al Ghul is doing is
legitimately right and so because of all
this we end up having once Batman's team
get in but the only way to actually get
out is taken out by El Diablo again this
guy who basically is a possession of a
fire demon and so because of this one is
up happening is this leads directly into
a direct conflict with the forces of
Batman and the forces of Ra's al Ghul at
the same time we also end up having
poison ivy brought into the fray Ra's al
Ghul would not be able to create this
sort of plant life would not be able to
create this ecosystem without the help
of poison ivy
remember poison ivy is part of the green
and that means that she's able to
basically manipulate all plant life on
the planet Earth she's basically an
elemental and so because of this she
along side Ra's al Ghul were able to
create this entire ecosystem this
massive place where all these animals
and all these plants could coexist in
perfect harmony and that's why it's cool
it's because despite the fact that
they're villains they've actually
created this small section of the world
that allows animal life to thrive
outside of humanity work out in the
normal world people are waging war
crimes are happening different things
like that which again brings it into the
equation did Batman really win if under
the rule of Superman there was no war
there was no crime outside of Batman and
his regime if there were no bank
robberies or anything like that and the
Batman says well no you know we need a
world where all these terrible things
happen we need a world where all this
crime happens did Batman really win did
Batman really make the world a better
place
I mean sure people have freedom but it's
a tough sell to tell some four-year-old
girl whose parents were killed well
that's just the price you pay for
freedom we could have had a world where
your parents lives but your parents
needed to die just because of the fact
that you know logic so because of that
it creates this really interesting
scenario with regards to all these
characters and how this all comes
together and how this all ends up
working together the problem with this
is that once Plastic Man and company
infiltrate the compound masquerading as
waz al Ghul and then they manage to grab
the kids and grab
Quinn and begin to make their escape
we're met with the presumed death of
Harley Quinn when the bomb that's inside
her head is supposed to be triggered by
this Jason Todd Batman remember when it
comes to Harley Quinn she's a member of
The Suicide Squad and so each member of
The Suicide Squad has had a bomb put in
their heads so that if they disobey
their orders the bombs will be detonated
and so what this looks like is that
Harley Quinn is going to die but would
that being said guys we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the rod Court if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]